conservatives want to see an end to the
blockades we want to see them ended
peacefully and quickly
in a way that canadians feel that
they've been listened to heard and
respected by their prime minister
we are concerned that the actions of the
prime minister will not have that effect
and in fact will have the opposite
effect today the prime minister
announced that he will be
invoking the emergencies act
we have to take a look at what he's
proposing and the rationale and
conservatives will discuss it and make a
determination in terms of whether we
will support it or not
at first blush we are very concerned
with what we see
first and foremost if you look across
the country provinces are not in
agreement with what the prime minister
is proposing
he has
said he has consulted but there there
really is not collaboration or agreement
alberta is opposed to it saskatchewan
manitoba and quebec
he's not off to a good start on that
secondly we have seen the prime minister
continually wedge divide and stigmatize
canadians who he doesn't agree with
and by doing so he creates so many
barriers in in terms of trying to solve
this problem
the prime minister had an opportunity to
talk and to listen to people who he
disagreed with and he refused to do so
and so this looks like a ham-fisted
approach that as i said will have the
opposite effect conservatives today
offered a reasonable solution that would
at least bring down the temperature we
asked the house of commons to vote on
our motion which asked the government to
provide a plan
in terms of ending the lockdown so we
wanted just the plan in place by the end
of this month
not unreasonable not an extreme ask
considering provinces are doing and
other jurisdictions are doing it as well
so there is concern with the prime
minister's uh
typical way of dealing with people he
disagrees with
and this measure does not alleviate
those concerns that we have but again
we're going to take a look at the
legislation we're going to take a look
at the rationale and make our decision
conservatives want the barricades to
come down we want this to end quickly
and peacefully but in a way that
canadians feel that they have been
listened to and that their prime
minister respects them we are concerned
that this measure will have the opposite
effect
i want the trucks to be moved i want the
blockades to be removed i want them to
be moved quickly quickly and peacefully
listen i'm not here to tell canadians
whether they can come to parliament hill
and peacefully and legally protest i
support that my job is not to hold
canadians to account my job is to hold
the prime minister to account and the
prime minister has done a
very poor job and i'm trying to measure
my words he's done a dismal job managing
this
showing canadians that he disagrees with
that he respects them even though he
disagrees with them so that's our
position we've been very clear on it we
support peaceful legal protests but we
want these blockades and these barriers
to be removed we're the party of not
only law and order but of a strong
canadian economy